i want to start by saying
uh congratulations on a fantastic season
i love this
whole season i cannot wait to see where
this thing goes
thanks so much that's amazing to hear
amazing to hear it said it's been a
labor of love so that's that's great
this is going to be a very highly
spoiler-filled interview and let's just
get started
um when we spoke at the junket with
ridley uh you mentioned you had an idea
for like five seasons
if you could actually do it is that
still the case like you have an arc of
five seasons
yes yes it is if i was forced to you
know truncate that arc
it could be truncated you know i think
you know
selectively taking certain events out
and put them putting certain things in
uh but hopefully yeah it's it's it's a
good long
you know five six season arc for the
whole thing
in terms of the map that exists now yes
right so do you
as it stands right now do you know how
the series ends
yes yes i do okay i am so curious
jumping into i'm going to ask you
something i'm going to read you some
questions that i normally don't do
because i actually prepped for this
interview
yeah and uh so if you see me looking
down it's because i have
questions so um let's start uh the first
thing is
after season the season one finale you
introduce mother's baby
which is not at all what people are
expecting i am curious
if the baby is a smaller version
of the creature we see in episode one
of the fossil of that snake it is that
that
breed of mistake with some differences
it's a hybrid
version of that yes there is definitely
a connection there it's definitely uh
dna is in common but there is a little
bit of a difference because
this one comes from mother so it has you
know some attributes that some of the
snakes that originally uh existed on the
planet do not
uh you mentioned in i don't think it's
not the finale it's one of the last
episodes of the season
there you mentioned that basically uh
they
the humans got blueprints for
uh for essentially mother and just built
without really knowing
uh what was this final function
how much is that a hint towards things
to come
it's a big hint for sure um and there's
definitely i think you know we lay out
in season one sort of the this kind of
mystery in terms of where did this
technology come from uh the mithraic you
know discovered it
encrypted in their scriptures were these
uh used
blueprints essentially these designs or
you know various technologies which they
proceeded to build and then used to
uh try almost won this war they
basically did win the war but they also
forced the end of the world in the
process
uh so that we do know we do know that
there is some
and we also know that there seems to be
a connection uh
between some of that technology and what
we have uh
found so far on kepler 22
i'm curious why does everyone go to the
planet
that everyone is going to is that from
the scriptures is that
yeah yeah i think in the scriptures
there you know in addition to all these
technological blueprints there is you
know
actual you know uh you know coordinates
for this planet
as well and it also happens to be i
think
that plus the idea that you know
throughout their own you know space
exploration
satellites and this and that they know
that this is the only place to go
where you can survive without the aid of
technology all the other
possibilities apparently have been
crossed off the list by this time
uh in future seasons do you plan on
showing more
on what happened to earth and uh sort of
what built to where we are
yeah absolutely there'll be more
flashbacks um
and perhaps you know some present day
uh earth uh peaks as well to see uh what
might be going on
uh there after uh you know after
everything is over
uh because there are still uh
necromancers
on earth uh they were left behind most
of them
uh the myth ray didn't obviously didn't
want to bring any with them they were
done with them
uh it didn't trust them uh so they
left them on earth except for the one
they found waiting for them
on 22v uh so there is that
ah that's a good hint um uh with stuff
like the voice of soul
um which has affected certain people um
do you know
how all of that is gonna play out in
terms of
because obviously um with travis's
character he's going
kind of crazy yeah you know yes yeah he
is
and you know with travis it's
interesting travis character
um because he was a little bit crazy
when he got there
you know what i mean he was already a
former child soldier who then changed
his face
and spent 12 years pretending to be um
this you know religious captain and you
know it has all of these
issues to begin with and then he starts
hearing the voice
and goes you know where he goes but i
think that's
that's kind of a clue the idea that you
know if you really look at it
uh there is some connection to be made
in terms of who hears the voice and when
uh and how many i really i think only
one person can hear it at a time
i have yeah i have noticed that um it
has gone
um yeah there's there's there's a lot
that you have not revealed yet
um yes yeah so are you willing to say
who actually impregnated mother
i i can't say who i can say how i think
she was digitally impregnated while she
was inside of the
simulation um so being that she is
advanced as she is
um you know just by getting this
basically the instructions for how to
build something you know in
inside of herself it's like a 3d printer
and if she can get the materials you
know in this case
one of the materials is plasma you know
human blood
uh to to build this thing it can be done
you know uh in a very different way than
you know a human being would
create a baby uh she could kind of
create anything inside of herself uh if
given you know the proper instructions
and
given the right materials so i'm curious
something that i've also wondered is
obviously with her eyes that's how she
becomes the necromancer
um what is it about have you sort of
thought about the technology
with the eyes and how this all works
because without the eyes
she can be killed in a millisecond yeah
she's vulnerable without the eyes the
eyes are sort of like
sort of like the plutonium you know in
the bomb it's like she has all of the
circuitry
you need all of that stuff if you just
have the eyes uh it's just kind of like
you you have some plutonium in your
hands but
they are essential it's kind of like or
if you have some
you know hardware and you need like a
dongle to make it work you know sort of
thing
it's that kind of idea so she has a lot
of stuff you know built into her body
but it can't be you know utilized and
activated without the eyes
i would imagine when you guys were
writing uh season one when you're
figuring it all out
there had to have been maybe possibly
some changes things you thought you were
gonna do
that maybe for budget or for time or
whatever reason
you couldn't pull off um can you share
any of that
um i'm trying to think i think there
were some
things that you know i think in addition
to mother's other abilities
you know and you see a little bit of it
um in the pilot she is able to
kind of make people see things that
aren't there you know when she makes
champions see her as his dead sibling
um so there were some there were a few
more moments where she was making people
see things that weren't there
uh rather you know that were very
expensive
uh and that didn't get yeah yeah
i i completely understand what you're
saying um
what is can you say any more about the
five-sided ship
that is in the desert oh yes uh the
pentagonal uh temple um
well i can say this i can say that there
are more of them
uh that you know according to the
scriptures there's five of them
there's five of them and uh and in each
of them it's supposed to be hidden
the answers to the the the sort of the
ultimate you know the mythic mysteries
the uh the thing everybody's trying to
uh get to the bottom of
um but beyond that i can't tell you too
much more uh except that
we will see uh we'll we'll see another
in season two
and uh i think we'll get a lot more uh
kind of into
what the what it is and how it works and
all that good stuff
uh what should people take from the
visions mother sees in the finale with
the creatures
by the hole in the ground and the other
thing that i can't even describe
yeah what could be like a robot suit i
don't even know what that is
yes i can actually i mean that that i
feel like i can illuminate a little bit
um in terms of what it is um so
basically
you know when she has that that dream
and she sees that thing and
that weird kind of helmet robot head
thing and you know it starts to you know
the
fuel blood starts gushing out of the uh
the front of it kind of the nozzle on
the front
um what that is uh there is actually an
android inside of that it's a sort of
like a birthing
prison sort of thing uh so their bodies
inside the pentagonal bottom half
the top piece is a helmet that goes over
the
android and the android then bursts
a circuit out the nozzle um so that's
essentially what that is that's kind of
what you're seeing this kind of
foreshadowing of
what's about to happen to her but she
can't quite put it together
uh but until the very last moment uh
when it's too late
in the finale you have the cave that
paul goes into
you see mother and father ship you see
other things on the wall that are almost
moving can you go into more detail about
that not too much except the idea that
obviously there was
obvious you know this is not a virgin
planet as we're coming to discover there
was a civilization here
and here we're seeing imagery that does
suggest on some level that
something that we know to have happened
uh
13 years ago uh here we see depicted on
a cave that was you know drawing that
was made
several hundred thousand years ago and
how can that be
um so i think that's sort of the uh the
question
that's kind of presented there but i
can't answer it but i mean that's uh
that's what it is
is it um i don't think you're gonna
answer me but i'm just gonna ask
how is have there been other
races that have responded to the
message that obviously we got on planet
earth
uh that have arrived on this planet
prior to humans
um i i would say this is more of a
human-centric
uh story in that sense yes
i would say i would say no no okay
i'm just gonna go out on a limb and just
answer that one
got it uh i've been very curious uh for
the entire season why campion
has not been affected by the radioactive
food um
how much of a story point is that going
to be as the as the series continues
uh a fairly significant one yeah i think
it definitely has a lot to do with you
know his
his destiny on this planet and um in the
role he's going to play
you know in the future but uh i can't
i can you know i will say you know it
definitely uh
it's not so concealed in terms of the
why of it all
uh you know what i mean i think it is it
is something we could potentially
uh figure out on some level um but yeah
it will get
we definitely deal with it down the line
and it pays off
in a significant way got it um
what uh how is marcus
how is our future seasons with marcus
with the way he is mentally right now
uh how is that sort of gonna play out in
season two what can you tease
well you know i think he's definitely he
he's gone as crazy as one can go
so the question is the you know where do
you go from there
and then kind of what's the next step
he's kind of been broken down to nothing
you know i you know he was this man who
was this
he grew up on earth as a child soldier
you know he was completely powerless and
he got to this planet
suddenly he was hearing a voice and
everyone was worshiping him and you know
and he lost his mind you know
essentially uh and in the process though
he's kind of been broken down
into this you know into these into his
most you know
essential elements as it were uh so i
think
in season two we're going to see a sort
of a rebirth
as it were sort of a new uh uh
he's gonna kind of redefine himself uh
in season two
uh everyone throughout the season sees
visions
they see things you know some of the
kids that have previously died
um what can you say about these visions
that everyone has been seeing
you know obviously i think that they're
they're they're all significant
um you know i think there's obviously
you know something something on this
planet that you know if you're
tuned into a certain wavelength you know
you are able to
to see things see things that might be
coming um
but beyond that you know i i can't say
too much about it i think uh those sorts
of things are kind of what they are
of course no i get it i'm just trying to
drill and see what i can do i love it i
love it
yeah you know um so uh what's up
actually with the planet paul tells his
mom they have to stay on this side
to give birth to the to the baby yes um
and he says
and he says it was so you know soul that
is like you got to do it on this side
um anything you want to say about that
well i would say
you know very much like earth you know
every region of this planet is very
different you know
so though we know what there is you know
a lot of what there is to know about the
region we spent uh
season one in the rest of the planet is
you know quite mysterious
uh in terms of all that so
you know i think and also too i think
you have to
you know i think one could also imagine
that
other things in terms of the
hallucinations the voice so on and so
forth
uh when you move to another part of the
planet those things are going to shift
as well
that you know we're dealing with things
that
you know that seems supernatural and and
maybe they are but i think
everything also has a technological
aspect to it uh
that you could apply here in a sort of
really
um calculated way got it
uh what can you actually say about the
history of the planet
that maybe hasn't been revealed in the
season
um and especially the creatures that are
devolving
yes well i think you know one thing
we've learned uh one of the things we've
learned are these creatures used to be
human beings
and uh and one might even imagine
uh for all we know that maybe human
beings evolves
here first uh we don't know um
so there is definitely a strong
connection uh with this place
and you know in humanity um
as we've come to understand it um but
you know the the idea
here too is that these for some reason
something has caused these human beings
to
you know kind of turn around and start
going the other direction
devolving you know but the question is
why you know why would that happen you
know what what
what purpose would that serve uh or what
you know
what what what could cause you know what
is that we don't know but we do know
that that's exactly what it was this
planet was populated by human beings
and for some reason they've all devolved
into these more animalistic versions of
ourselves you know these kind of
you know walking around in all fours you
know very animalistic completely
devoid of all the things that you know
today we you know
herald is making humans humans uh are
mother and father going to be upset they
didn't kill the baby
when they had the chance uh
more well i won't answer that but i
wouldn't say this it definitely seems
like that was
given the the last shot of the the the
finale there
it does seem like that one would regret
that yeah that they
they missed an opportunity to uh to at
least try and destroy it uh while it was
small
uh because it's no longer that for sure
so uh
yeah i imagine there's a lot of regret
there but of course we don't know
if mother and father even you know what
becomes of them after they're shot out
of the uh
out of the hole there on the other side
of the planet but uh i'm gonna go up
i'm gonna go out there on a ledge due to
their performances as actors they will
survive into season two
yeah i think it's probably uh from a tv
standpoint i think that's a pretty safe
um i am willing to wager they will be
around um
how did they all survive going through
the middle of the planet
well again yeah it's like you can look
at the supernatural
uh possibilities and then you can look
at are there you know other things that
could be at play here that that would
make that possible
you know uh because we you know we're
saying okay this is a planet and
what do we know about planets and we're
applying all of that to this planet
but this planet is very very far away
from this one and they have attributes
that our planet does not despite the
fact that
you know it's a goldilocks planet and
you know on the surface it does seem to
have a lot in common with earth
uh but you know that's on the outside
you know like i've said uh
this planet is kind of like a haunted
house and it's got a whole ton of
secrets you know a whole lot
that goes along with it that you know
the people who just moved in aren't
really aware of yet
um so i think that would speak to the
you know what happens here this is this
idea that they have passed through
shot out the other side but again i
would say that this this is not
like uh this is not like earth in the
sense that um
taking a trip through the middle of it
is uh patently impossible
got it now i just sort of figured out
how you can connect
um different groups in season two if you
can travel through the middle
you know well it is well they've managed
to do it yes yes so i think it's not i
wouldn't recommend it as uh you know
just taking a jaunt back and forth that
it might not survive but yes
it can be done yeah you also had a huge
spaceship show up at the end too so
everything everything is possible um
what can you say about the tropical side
well
um it's fairly mysterious at this point
in the story for sure
we all know uh we know that this is sort
of the most bountiful place on the
planet so everyone believes this is
where
you know it seems like whoever is able
to plant their flag and really
um you know stake their claim to the
tropical zone
may become the dominant force on this
planet you know
forever you know kind of thing it's like
the that book uh gun storms and steel
about
you know about earth and you just the
idea of you know where people
you know just by chance end up evolving
on our planet geographically and what
you know what you know what they have
there you know what materials and
weather and all of these things that you
know
kind of come into play then you know
thousands of years later they end up you
know dominating the planet because of it
um and you know these folks coming to
kepler know that
quite well so they're they're trying to
uh stake their claim to the tropical
zone so of course tropical zone also has
this other weird
attribute which is the electromagnetic
field that prevents anyone from landing
directly in the tropical zone
uh which again might which also plays
into your
earlier question i think about you know
different sides of the planet
and the voice and uh things like that
and how these things might uh
interact with each other yeah i'm still
looking forward already to season two
uh was the atheist ship always going to
arrive in the finale
could be thousands of people it could be
ten people
exactly so we don't really know uh we
also kind of got the impression that
the atheists weren't as advanced as the
myth rag the mithraic had all these
uh you know like quantum gravity you
know propulsion machine you know that
stuff was in their scriptures as well
uh what i one thing i will say about
season two is that this ship
was actually built by the mithraic uh it
was hijacked while it was under
construction
uh on earth so the the people aboard the
ship are in fact
atheists but uh but again in terms of
the technology
it's uh it's more uh mythranic stuff got
it
uh the snake creature is pretty large as
it exits the ship
how much larger can it get um i won't
answer that though i would say
it's pretty darn large right now you
know but uh
i'll i'll leave that one open i i'm a
huge fan of godzilla but i also
uh i also like to keep things manageable
so we'll see
got it um well jumping into season two
for a second um when did you know you
were getting the pickup versus when they
officially announced it
um a little bit earlier you know i i
mean
it's kind of a hard question to answer
you know i think uh but uh
i always just assume that you know it's
just gonna keep going because i know if
i don't if i
stop thinking about it then if it does
keep going i'll it'll be too late for me
to figure it all out
so i just have to keep keep assuming
it's going to keep going until someone
tells me to stop
so that's all i can do so i guess my
thing is so
where are you in the writing process of
season two
um i think in terms of the planning of
it i'm fairly well into it
fairly well it's fairly worked out you
know in terms of the outlining and
uh all of that good stuff uh scripts
aren't done
you're like that no
i got it uh do you have a plan of when
you might be filming
um i can't say specifically but you know
hopefully quite soon you know i mean
we'll see how things go uh you know with
the virus and
and you know just uh best practices and
all that good stuff but uh
uh hopefully soon i think uh that's
that's our intent to uh
you know get going as soon as we can
well i was gonna say what's interesting
about your show
is that it's not a show that requires
hundreds of extras
and you know like you have very you have
a small
cast in you know in terms of trying to
pull this off does that make it easier
to shoot
in in the covid times um you know
i guess we'll know when when we get
there but uh one would assume so yeah i
mean obviously
crowds and you know lots and lots of
humans and small
spaces uh all very bad so uh
we'll have to see you know i mean yeah i
think we are bringing in more people for
season two
so uh there'll be a little bit more in
terms of the the population
but uh but still i think you know
compared to something
that's about earth you know where we're
you know crowds crowds crowds no
we're lucky in that sense yeah uh what
was your shooting schedule on season one
and did hbo give you like any additional
days
for season two um
i think it'll be fairly similar we had a
pretty good schedule for season one
uh fairly good amount of time to to get
done what we needed to get done and you
know ridley really set the
uh set the pace for season one and he is
just like the most efficient director
known to man and he was you know
starts in the morning boom boom boom
boom boom gets more done than you
thought
possible and your everyone's done you
know same time every day
you know and i think it just the
efficiency and the crews there are just
incredible everybody is just like
so on it so uh yeah hopefully it's just
gonna be that same sort of thing where
it's just well-oiled machine
and and uh just keep cranking it out i
think the other good thing is we don't
have to do a lot of night stuff because
uh
we're on an alien planet so we can kind
of create we have three moons
uh which you know creates a very you
know specific sort of night uh
and that helps a lot dude
that's where things get tough especially
now with uh with covet and everything
i'm sure all the tougher
you didn't actually answer so i'll do a
little further um was it like an
eight-day shooting schedule was it a
12-day
uh it was i think it was somewhere in
between somewhere in between
i i read the the pilot in episode two is
a little bit longer
and then it got a little bit shorter for
the uh for the following blocks uh and
we cross
uh cross-bordered it so we did you know
two at a time
completely and uh but yeah somewhere in
between there
are you gonna bring back um any of the
directors you had on season one
um and if i could sort of say will
ridley be coming back
um we will see ridley's extraordinarily
busy right now he's you know he's
finishing his movie i think he's got a
movie to do right after that
um he has expressed interest but i don't
know that the schedule is going to work
out but
you know who the heck knows um and
directors were we're figuring that out
now we're gonna
hopefully uh have some clarity soon but
uh
but right now we're not sure well what's
interesting is at
when you do for the first season you
really don't know what the show is going
to be no one really knows what the show
is
but now you actually can show directors
well this is what we made
do you want to play in our play in our
sandbox yeah
because it has a very specific you know
obviously style i think because we
really wanted to
you know do something where you know
ridley sets the style and you know the
kind of the template for how this is
going to work
in every director that comes in after
obviously can is going to bring their
own you know flavor to it but at the
same time we do want to kind of
make it feel as consistent as possible
you know where it's not so much like
every episode feels like it's you know a
different color or different coming from
a different place
uh really want to just play like one
long movie where you don't really
it's not so uh noticeable you know the
director's coming and going
um so hopefully we can maintain that for
the season two when you make the first
season of any show
it is a learning process in terms of how
much
you can shoot in your schedule what the
money you have for visual effects
you know it's basically figuring out the
infrastructure of how to make a show
what did you learn making season one
that you hope to
sort of benefit from while making season
two
um i guess uh it's let me see here
well definitely learned a lot in terms
of you know the types of
you know special effects that we can you
know that can be done cheaply and those
that cannot
and you know how to kind of cheat things
a little bit to kind of uh just get more
bang for your buck in terms of
all the effects you know we're trying to
do in this show uh but at the same time
trying to do
some of them you know practically and
you know and just figuring out ways to
uh just to be as efficient as possible
everything everything on the screen
um in terms of like specific lessons
it's interesting
i would say that the one thing i can say
is that season two will take place in a
very different uh
region on the planet so a lot of the
lessons that i learned
season one won't even apply uh so
it's kind of like you know like i've
been in uh you know
uh california in season one and now i'm
going to you know michigan for
season two and it just you know the
climate is very different
and uh the geography and all that good
stuff so uh
unfortunately i think a lot of those
lessons will be moot uh in this case
how does it work with the executives at
hbo max so
you you obviously delivered season one
they they saw it they loved it they gave
you another season
how much do you have to go in and sort
of pitch them
on your vision for season two and you
know
all that stuff and how much is it you
know them saying oh you did a really
good job
go for it yeah uh it's a little bit of
both i think you're always gonna have to
tell them
you know what the plan is i think um at
least i do i haven't gotten to a place
in my career they're just like just go
for it and we'll you know
we trust whatever you want don't even
tell us what you're going to do
i got so i had to work it out and pitch
them and you know and pitch them again
and uh um but they have faith you know i
think
it's not his case where i think we both
they know what kind of show we're making
they're not trying to make it into a
different show i think they just wanted
to you know
help make it as great as it can be and
you know give it the most oxygen
it can have and you know all the things
it needs to have a good life um so
they've been really
they've been really great partners they
haven't tried to i think that's my
biggest
thing is that you know they could have
come in and been like all right well
let's try and you know change this
around make it this a little bit more
like this so it's a little bit more
recognizable a little easier to
sell or whatever it is they didn't do
that so
um you know it's been it's been great in
that respect but yes i still have to
kind of like okay here's here's what the
plan is here's the story
here's where this goes here's where that
goes and just kind of make everybody
feel
you know comfortable that uh you know
i'm not just some
madman driving them into uh you know a
brick wall
somewhere completely it's my last
question for you because i'm out of time
um you had 10 episodes in the first
season was it ever gonna be
eight or a different number and will it
be ten episodes again with season two
um remains to be seen uh but no it was
always gonna be ten for season one
uh season two will say uh could
potentially be
eight but we'll see eight or ten i think
eight is the new ten now is what i'm
hearing
for uh for streaming well what's funny
is
um i personally think that more people
are willing to invest their time
when it's shorter seasons um yeah me too
yeah i think so i mean obviously it's
the it's our
nobody has time for anything now and uh
so but
you know i think uh you need enough time
to really and i think eight
is enough i think that's about as short
as i could go and still
feel like we're telling a complete you
know novel of a
story uh you know because i my the show
i did previously
uh the red road i did many years ago we
only had six
uh six second seasons which was
which was cool but it was always felt a
little too short it was almost just kind
of like yeah you just need one or two to
really
hammer it home you know it always felt
like you were being uh you know kind of
pulled off the stage a little too early
there but i think eight is kind of a
good number but 10
is is good too listen i really want to
say sincerely i loved this first season
uh thank you so much for getting on the
zoom call with me
to discuss uh spoilers and and hopefully
down the road we will do this again
that would be great